こんにちははじめ社長です皆様は表情どれくらい大切にしてますか人には様々な表情が
あります
笑顔悲しい顔怒った顔ちょっテリー
切なそうな顔胸像はとても大切です1つのドラマ度シーンがあるとしましょう
そのシーンを様々な表情とやってみたらちょっとしたら
表情の大切さがわかるかも知れませんでというわけで今日は
一回やったわ1回ありましたね昔もやったんですけども一つの演技を一つのドラマの c
みたいなのに今からやるんですけども
もしそのシーンを仮に様々な表情でやってみたらそのドラマのマン c はどのように
変わるのか一緒に見ていきましょう
今回やらしいはこちらです
俺はバタフライなぁむつ通称バターというバンドを組んでいる
メンバーがギターの俺ベースの竹中ボーカルの灯りの3人た津波によるは
ばかりと付き合っている初の路上ライブが間近に迫っていて練習もラストスタート
そんな中居れば
2人のとんでもない関係を知ってしまった
[音楽]
なんだ枝急に呼び出して
お前
俺が彼に中出したらあっ
何のことだとぼげんじゃねぇ
me
んだよ
スタジオの練習悪に見ちまったッ
お前らが耳たぶくっつけながら歩いているところを
得られてたのかよ俺たちも解散だな
[音楽]
お前とはうまくやっていけると思ったのに
行け方とでしょうか前回より結構ブラックなシーンですね&チューブ内の男女関係非常
に複雑ですね
次に今回はこちらのシーンを様々な表情でやってみたいと思いますではやっていき
ましょう
雲よ
true
[音楽]
ランドリーダー
牛乳を言い出して
[音楽]
思われ
俺流れ出ているだろうはぁんっ
卵のことだよとぼけんじゃねぇいっ
だよスタジオの練習終わりに見ちまったんだよ
お前らがユタをくっつけながら歩いてるところ
いられてた高や俺たちもうかいざんだなあああ
[音楽]
お前とうまくやっていけると思ったのによ
反対だ
急に呼び出して
お前
[音楽]
俺がバレ見て出したらあっ
何のことだ時計じゃねぇ
tue
[音楽]
だやースタジオの練習終わりに見ちまったんだよ
お前が耳たぶくっつけながら増えているところ
ん
を得られてるかよ俺たちも解散だな
[音楽]
ああ
お前とはうまくやできると思ったのには
[音楽]
あっはい
カバー
なんで上田急流でしてどんなクルマだった
それも稀
米の仮に手出したらあなんだことだよ
道元じゃないあっ
はっはっは
んだよ
普通の悪い見ちまったんだよ
お前らたを指た振っ作りながら歩いてところなんてっ
見られたるかよ
俺たちも解散だな
[音楽]
ああ
はっはっは
[音楽]
あっはああを巻きカワウは結構やっていけると思ったらいいやー
なんだリラー急に呼び出してねー
[音楽]
お前
俺中に手出したらああ
何のことだよどけじゃねぇ
いっ
だよ
スタジオの練習悪い見ちまったんだよ
お前らが耳たぶくっつけながら歩いているところ
見られてたのかよ俺たちも解散だなあー
[音楽]
うん
お前とはうまくやっていけると思ったのに
[音楽]
なんだリーダー急に呼び出して
お前
覚えの別れに手ぇ出したらだ
あ
何のことだよ鳳凰堂も切るとねー
んだよ
えええええええ
た上の練習はに見ちまったんだよ
シェアハーン
お前らが耳朶をつけながら歩いてるところ
見られてたのかよ ua 折れちゃっ家も解散だら
うわぁ
[音楽]
お前とハうまくやっていけると思ったのによってえっ
ん